thinking of a fruit basket what anime
are you uh into what are you watching i
love spy family of course
who doesn't wow are you also part of the
human race
it's so cute it's by x family i can't
believe you so you're the spy family
yeah i've been catching up with jiu
jitsu kaisen okay funny enough it was
really funny the last right now i'm on
episode 16 17. what just okay yeah yeah
yeah but uh i remember at the very
beginning the very beginning of this
episode
uh this is kind of when they sort of go
into panda's backstory and also the
robot guy yeah oh that fight yeah yeah
and at the very beginning of the episode
i was like man it's been like 16
episodes but like i'm still not super
invested in this show yeah maybe like
maybe it's just not my thing we'll see
right and i watched it and like this one
was just so
cute and like emotional and like at the
end the episode was done dice was like
oh no i'm crying a little bit and then
and then i turned around with like tears
screaming
oh my god so cute so i like it so you
think it's better than okay
yeah for a while i was like
you hear that you hear that it's it's
not mid would you say it's better than
mid
well
if a show takes like 16 episodes for me
to like feel something yeah i thought it
was better than that
no no no no also your brother gets like
the best part yeah yeah it's gonna get
better so that's the thing i i don't
like it when someone's like oh it'll get
better after like 55 episodes wait i i
like sakuna
i think it's because like i'm not built
for shonen
like
what are you built for what are you what
are you built for different
[Laughter]
i'm mildew you should tell shonen fans
that no again what are you built for i
don't want to be crucified but like i
think because i love watching like
funny like goofy
anime that when i was watching jutsu
kaisen live i didn't really care that
much about the fights like they're like
sick but like it's a shonen fight yeah
yeah also like i feel like yuji's just
like every other shonen pro tag that
i've ever seen i'm sorry the kaisen fans
are quaking right now dude
she's right you know
what the [ __ ] no dude put the pitch
folks down
no like like i remember when i first
started watching i was like i don't get
what is so special about this show like
it's not that's exactly how i felt about
it you know what is this [ __ ] slander
going on over here it is
it is like it is i said this when i made
like a shout-out this is 100 percent of
the hmong readers because i've heard it
gets
[ __ ] incredible which i'm sure it
does i really like it
to say this literally allison was like
on my on my side of things where i was
like jesus guys was okay and then like
he went off to read the manga and he was
like [ __ ] i hate to admit that shonen
fans were right but they're right
and i'm like if if alan can admit that
i'm like okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah i i absolutely love
the first season i thought it was one of
the best showing that we had in a while
my favorite moments like the parts that
i liked the most in jiu jitsu were like
the goofy moments the goofy moments like
the goofy little then you must love like
todo right total total was his name yeah
the the guy who's obsessed with that
yeah no i don't like him
what he's weird i don't like him
he's literally like the best dude i
don't like he's confusing okay well okay
give it a few episodes he gets even
better okay okay
how do you know mikey what the [ __ ] he's
so charming and like the robot guy i was
like and he's whatever he's just like a
robot guy okay yeah and then they got
into like his backstory yeah and like at
the very end when like it's just a cute
little moment she has with his friends
yeah another like to depend on him i was
like oh that's so sweet
but all the fighting stuff
so you just like your mind just goes
whenever they like they start fighting
yeah right so you just want like you
just want like the pandas just like [ __ ]
and fart everywhere and then like that's
that's like amusing man peter's so cute
so basically if if if you if there was
like a spin-off of jesus christ saying
where just went over panda's stuff yeah
just be like not just oh like just them
being a homie
so basically if there was a slice of
life spin-off of jesus christ where all
the characters are just kind of hanging
out
bro emily would see like [ __ ] jesus
on the cross be like yeah
no
like the little
second the second ending we're all
together panda's wearing like a scarf
and ear muffs and it's all cute and
they're all just being friends are we
watching the same [ __ ] show like what
are you watching here like what are you
getting out of this emily's gonna get to
the [ __ ] hanami fight where just like
like
spoilers you know when it when it's just
like [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
it's the fight where all the cool [ __ ]
happens yeah yeah hey
[Music]
you literally want them to just like
animate a full series of just like the
ed well you know it's just you know
where like they go shopping and
everything like that have all the bags
all the bags give me the backstory
i think that's why i love spy family so
much it's just like goofy shenanigans
yeah the steaks are not high yeah so you
don't lower your steaks
i just don't want to be stressed out
what the actual [ __ ] emily what are you
talking about
you mean like giving a [ __ ] about like
the plot
no i give a [ __ ] about the plot but like
what's my family so you don't like stuff
that makes you stressed out not too
stressed out if you watched like uh
uncut gems or um
uh what's the other one that they did um
[ __ ] is the other rod pat's and good
time you watched that one oh daddies
watching are those movies yeah
why is it different why is it different
because shows are so much longer i don't
i'm stressed out for a little it's not
all like [ __ ] edging like there's
like there's parts where like there is
tension and it gets resolved i mean yeah
i don't know maybe just like it's like i
don't just encounter it's a movie what
are you talking about
it's so weird how like you're so
committed because it's in a show form
but then when you look at the individual
scenes you're not committed at all
it's like i don't care about this fight
i'm not committed who's that one
character with the blue hair he pisses
me off the long-haired guy and which
show did you to kyson well oh the the
like the animal dude oh the one on the
other like school from kyoto
oh oh that guy i really like the episode
where he got his ass beat that was funny
but what anime do you like then if you
don't like tell them
yeah fruits yeah
it should be called mid basket
because that's what it is dude
you know what i can't even
made best that's a hot take right there
i like when an anime is just a good time
and it feels good like fruit basket is
like you've watched
this really dramatic honey have you
watched uh teletubbies she might like
that one actually
thomas the tank i think it's like right
up here
i really enjoyed my dress-up darling
that was really good
yeah of course
what else
why are you grilling me i just want to
know what else that's too high stakes
apparently okay wait you know what
dramatic show i really liked actually
fine ed but that also kind of took a
while to that first argument
both oh okay it's good that's good of
course so wait wait that's way more like
horrible than that that's like way more
like dramatic and traumatizing
what's
medicine and like a slice of cheese it's
like take take the dramatic pill take
the tension pillow what you're saying is
you would be more invested in the juices
kaisen scene if a scene before they were
shopping
no yeah that's basically what you're
saying it's like okay okay okay and then
bam what about uh they're seen in
judicial i really liked
when uh well that big guy was telling
mai to
he gave her a ticket to see that one
idol and like yeah
she was like pretending she didn't like
it that was cute
and you still and you still don't like
toto
literally the most minor scene in the
entire show was like yeah that that's
the that's the highlight i think about
um uh madoka magica i liked it
that was pretty [ __ ] dark yeah that
was that's like suffer porn the anime
well that's different what what about
this difference
there was fights in there
is it cause madoka's wearing pink
no it's because it's magical girl that's
why yeah anything with magical girl
should just leave so if you just did any
show but it was a shonen i'd be like
so if they were wearing magical girl
outfits jiu-jitsu
would you be more inclined hell yeah
it's all about the aesthetics
okay
nothing about that was funny what no
like the joke got stale after one
episode okay she's dumb i get it oh i
really like it
[Laughter]
um i didn't see the second season of one
punch man but
you don't you don't need to you don't
need them
did you enjoy the first season of one
punch yeah i mean it's great
it is very good it is really good i love
like goofy stuff did you like death note
i did
but that also has tension i just you saw
me say misa you were like i am invested
allow me to pay attention no that's not
true
are you are you telling me honestly that
when meesa came in death no they're not
throwing hands in death note
so murder's okay as long as they don't
get physical
[Laughter]
i think i think psychological trauma is
fine physical trauma is a no-no mr kerfs
just doesn't get pushed
[Laughter]
how dare you adopt my language the
greatest showdown fights of all time the
fisticuff have you watched what about uh
man
did you watch uh
i think you just don't like fighting
right that's yeah that's it right but
she likes one punch man that's different
she's not fighting that's that's that's
murder that's that's he murders that man
well like you know he's gonna win yeah
right
you don't like fights that okay so let
me get this straight you don't like
fight scenes in anime where you don't
know if the main guy's gonna win or not
no
that's what it's sounding like i just i
like i like low stakes you know like you
know he's gonna be okay so i can watch
that's most anime
that's most anime fights true because
otherwise you're just anger you're like
you like this in real life yuji
literally died well he came back but
you could literally die the stakes are
high
oh yeah he does yeah
complete but i mean like we all knew he
was going to go we all knew he was going
to come back is this some like childhood
like thing where you're like you just
hate like seeing
people fight in movies or something i
don't know
i mean yeah i
i kind of get it because no i don't i
don't at all
oh you don't [ __ ] get it don't
pretend like you're just trying to be
nice don't
i get it because sydney hayes fights as
well unfortunately and i have to live
with that and i'm just like sydney look
at this amazing action scene and she's
like bro but like but like like sex is
just cooperative fighting that's just
like
she likes that that's so sore come on
fight i just want to show uh have you
seen bucky at all no oh my god i just
want to show you one scene of blockies
i want you to film that [ __ ] because
it would be sexy because no just like
anything because it's like ridiculous
it's everything it's everything emily
hates it's like ridiculous
wait have you seen jojo emily
[Laughter]
what are you saying
no it's just the castle
we don't like the muscles i love him i
love that emily's reacting as if you
showed her like gallport yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's literally just a bog again
in one of the scenes one of the
characters can make like a demon face
with his back muscles
yeah and then everyone's like it's the
demon face oh [ __ ]
it seems like it seems like like a jojo
fan type of show
i was gonna ask have you seen jojo
no i have no idea why i don't know if
i'd be into it you know what you know
what twitter post i keep thinking of
when i hear jojo what what i've seen
that post that's like jojo fans be like
oh my god he's so hot ben proceeds to
show me the uglies
[Laughter]
i hate how she like that character
that is literally one of the characters
that's literally what he looks like
iraqi fan's quaking right now
i i don't know i mean i think you should
try jojo you might actually enjoy it
because it's really goofy yeah yeah it's
really really strange
it's like so serious that it's like the
most goofiest thing in the world yeah
it's like imagine making like a fight
out of like someone holding in a fart
like that's like basically jojo fights
like it's it's it's like keep up like
how do you follow it though you start
with part one i don't know just like
i don't know and then it's part three
and you just keep going in order but
like most of the memes are from one to
five at the moment because like no
nobody's read the manga really i mean
like yeah hardcore fans have but like
people only meme the anime stuff
but like even like from like the first
episode you'll start recognizing memes
okay which is like kind of fun it's like
spot the meme it's like one of the most
famous memes is from episode one yeah to
be continued
there's like so many memes in episodes
it's like a meme bingo yeah
i was thinking about jojo memes i was
like that's not there's not a lot of
part one oh no wait a minute it's just
been so long since i've seen part one
memes literally most do memes part one
yeah yeah and then you can watch the
like the jojo music meme
you can watch it
i've seen and yet i still don't know a
single thing about the show that's like
most people though yeah that's jojo in a
nutshell
i could spoil the entirety of like a
part that hasn't been animated and
you'll probably be like i gained no
information from that whatsoever yeah
and you could probably still go into it
like one of the villains
in one part is the president of the
united states of america and they have
to like resurrect jesus christ to like
help is it the actual like president
yeah in the show yeah the action oh no
it's it's like the president in this
university in the university for a
second i thought colin's taking the piss
and i was talking about metal gear solid
which i'm just like
which is also like a senator that's a
senator by the way
i made it the [ __ ]
okay that's two metal gears games then
because like in one of the main games
like the main uh the president is like
the bad guy as well yeah exactly it's
good it's good it's uh yeah you should
read it or watch it it's fun i'll give
it a shot you should watch your diet
actually die just like complains about
everything don't want your daughters
he does he literally like will watch one
thing like oh [ __ ] actually